I'm pleased to welcome back to the
program longtime friend of the show bill
scher contributing editor to Politico
magazine he's got an article from a week
or two ago called the single-payer
insanity the Democrats presidential
contenders are rushing to embrace Bernie
Sanders Medicare for all plan have they
learned nothing the headline said so
bill let's I mean I I've gotten some
emails from people who are a little
bummed out about this article and they
said you've got it you've got to figure
out exactly where bill is on this can
you first just outline for the for the
benefit of the audience what is your
personal view on single-payer versus how
does it relate to what you think is good
strategy for Democrats uh I am strongly
for universal coverage and I'm policy
agnostic how you get there okay if if I
was president and the country was 80%
for single-payer and it flew through the
Congress and landed on my desk you know
sure I'd sign that but that doesn't mean
there aren't other ways to get to
universal coverage and now we're in a
situation where we have had three
decades of painful health care political
fights yep we had the Hillary care fight
in the 90s we had the Obamacare fight in
2009-2010 we've had the Obamacare repeal
fight this year no one has come out
unscathed for any of these fights
whether you're coming from the left or
the right all the from the Democratic
perspective you know Hillary care didn't
even happen and you lost the Congress
Obamacare actually managed to get passed
but you still lost the Congress and
arguably contributed losing the
presidency and now Republicans tried to
yank it back and now are they unable to
do it you literally have the president's
hanging his own Senate Majority Leader
and speaker for failing to do it which
could may well jeopardize their control
of Congress if if this leads to a loss
of Republican turnout come 2018 so
you're James Carville had a quote
earlier this year the mover on health
loses there's no way to propose anything
significant in health care without there
being either real real winners or losers
substantively or perceived and the
losers are the ones that speak up the
loudest and cause political damage to
the politician making the move yeah but
isn't there something to be said for the
timing I mean on the one hand you could
say hey it's great that Bernie has now
decided to propose Medicare for all 2017
there's no shot of that happening you've
got Republicans controlling the house
the Senate and the White House so it's a
really easy political move but what
about the other side of that which is
now that there's not actually the
possibility of it passing is it time to
start getting the idea of it into the
public sort of discourse as you point
out in the article it is something that
generally speaking more than half of the
country supports and even if you're not
going to actually legislate it because
it will never pass isn't this a good
time to start talking about it here's
the problem III with as a general matter
it is healthy to propose big ideas shape
the debate try to move the center of
political gravity your way you don't get
exactly what you lay out in the
beginning if you get something if you
get half a loaf a half is better than
nothing
you know that's all generally true
what's different in this case is so
number one Democrats are expended a lot
of political capital to build the
framework of the Affordable Care Act
which has gotten us 90% of the way to
universal coverage and there is a way to
get to 100% with the existing framework
now mere proposing an idea typically
there's nothing there's not necessarily
a cost that comes with that there can be
a political cost if you're proposing
something that is manifestly unpopular
and therefore you will lose an election
because of that as you point out and as
other single payer advocates point out
polling wise at least on the top line
the words single-payer I generate over
50 percent support in some polls
Medicare for all it's even a little
better it's more like 57% people who are
advocates can overstate the strength of
those polls because there are other
polls that bring up critiques that show
those numbers can swing wildly once you
get into the meat of the debate but I'm
not saying that if Democrats get behind
this they are surely to lose in 2018 or
2020 I can't I can't prove that what I
do think is very risky and dangerous for
Democrats is raising expectations to
unrealistic levels so if Democrat let's
say Democrats win the Congress in 2018
and they win the presidency in 2020
there there isn't a sense of strategic
sensibility I would argue amongst most
single graphic it's maybe some do I
generally hear from people the people
want this health care there should be no
profit in health care there's no way to
get to universal coverage with
affordable care with the affordable care
act we have to do this it's a moral
imperative if people have that level of
expectation and they get a rude
awakening
come 2021 you're gonna suffer what
Republicans are suffering right now
which is recrimination you promised us
this you said you're gonna repeal
Obamacare and now you're telling me it's
too complicated well screw you
use that a guy in Alabama Luther strange
he literally voted to repeal Obamacare
and he's still got attacked because the
Republicans couldn't get done Mitch
McConnell could have get done you're
close to him it's your fault that could
easily be the case in 2021 if Democrats
are saying well I I said I was for
single-payer but now I know it's too
complicated there's too many transition
causes too much disruption I can't
really do it there's gonna be a price to
pay if that happens well I think that
that's true but I think that the people
who now are co-sponsoring Bernie's bill
just for example are not the more sort
of corporate centrist Democrats most
likely to take that approach in a few
years but I want to think more about now
because you said something interesting
which is you've got this infrastructure
of Obamacare and you and I both know
that if it weren't for significant
obstruction from Republicans there would
actually be some pretty specific fixes
that Republicans and Democrats could
come together and do and they would fix
some of
the problems with in Obamacare most of
which are sort of I believe related to
the fact that it just further in grains
the for-profit health care system and
the problems within that but you and I
would agree
there's fixes to Obamacare that could be
made why not consider rather than the
debate being repeal and replace
Obamacare with Trump Care 3.0 or
whichever version of the bill there is
or keep what we have now why not make
the sort of range of ideas okay well
Republicans want to repeal and replace
and 32 million people will end up
without coverage Bernie and a number of
other Democrats have co-sponsored
Medicare for all 2017 let's come to the
middle and just make a few fixes to
Obamacare like wouldn't that in some way
maybe make it more likely that the fixes
to Obamacare get done IIIi don't think
so in this case the the way to get to I
mean it's very hard to anything in the
current environment without
bipartisanship yeah and as we know from
the past since Republicans took the
Congress in 2010 that means doing very
little there there's very little space
of common ground to do to do usually
can't do big things with the way things
are as it stands the things that have
gotten done have gotten done because
they went below the radar
they weren't above the radar there are
fixes that could be done that if they
were interpret as a giving the other
side a political victory then maybe you
could get them done once Republicans and
I think we're we're inching closer to
the point where Republicans are gonna
have to admit look Affordable Care Act
is law of the land
it is to Emes in the fabric of society
now you can't undo it without causing
massive disruption we have to accept it
as it is and now let's try to make it
work as well as well as possible if
that's not gonna happen
you know tomorrow but the farther you
get away from the Obama presidency the
firmer you get away from the irrational
spite Republicans have Republicans have
towards him the closer you can get there
so I don't think having a fresh
ideological battle over do you want
government involvement in health care or
not I don't think that that moves you
naturally towards let's have some
incremental
by parsing technical fixes mean the
things that should be done quite frankly
are are even not that simple let's
increase the individual mandate penalty
so people aren't being Free Riders
let's find a way to empower the
independent Medicare advisory payments
Board so we have some more cost controls
let's maybe is way to juice the
subsidies for those who are applying for
hardship exemptions right now those
Republican governors and they're in the
more conservative states may then get
over their their spite and actually
expand Medicaid I don't think having the
single-payer argument automatically
moves you there
and I think there's a whole host of
other issues that are really on the
sidelines climate infrastructure the
future of work immigration that's a good
I'm glad you're mentioning that because
that's one part of your article where
you say quote there are more pressing
issues to confront I guess I don't
understand why if you say hey our
position or the position of this group
of Democrats or whoever is that we
believe the ideal system is Medicare for
all and we will work within reason with
Republicans to improve the system we
have up until such point until Medicare
for all is viable then confront all the
other issues right it felt kind of like
a nobody can walk and chew gum at the
same time type of assertion well it's
not that health care is not pressing
obviously if you don't have health
insurance or your health sure is
insufficient that is that is a pressing
issue for you single-payer is not a
pressing policy goal because there are
other means to get to universal coverage
now I get a lot of people are dying well
if people are dying take the fastest
path to solving that problem not the
long drawn-out protracted ideological
path if there's a lot of obvious
obstacles are gonna be in your way so
and I and there's a political argument
to make which is look Democrats can't
can't run on walkush technocratic
policies it was Mario Cuomo said you you
you campaign in poetry you govern in
prose we don't don't go campaigning in
prose I get that but campaigning on big
ideas you know comes with inherent
difficulties it's not like the farthest
left candy and the farthest
can a twin every election in which they
participated in many cases they don't so
you got to pick your spots and
healthcare we have three decades of
evidence that that is a very difficult
spot to pick
it's like Obama ran on health care as a
signature policy plan in the general
election no but I think that one
interesting aspect there is you mention
hey listen more than 90 percent of
voters support requiring background
checks for gun buyers yet we ended up
with a president who doesn't believe
that isn't there every indication that
people vote more on health care versus
on gun control in other words recent
Gallup poll which looks at what are the
most important vote abolitions for
people while people may have very strong
opinions on gun control and background
checks health care always ranks much
much higher in terms of the most
important issues in deciding on who to
vote for and thus if you do find a
position like health care for all
single-payer whatever that is palatable
to people it might actually influence
voting more significantly than the
background check thing well I'm not
arguing that gun control is somehow a
magical political issue for Democrats to
stand out I did actually see a poll just
this morning that was taken in August by
I think NBC Wall Street Journal that
actually said the opposite that actually
had guns at the top of the list
interesting of things that were would
make you would shape your voting
decision I mean it wasn't 50 percent it
was thirty five percent but out of the
list of issues that was the number one
okay so it may just be how you word the
question or what people's mood or a
particular day yeah so I there's clearly
a single-payer movement there's clear
that it is their top issue I don't think
Bernie would make this his number one
issue if that movement didn't exist and
there's Khalid people on the
conservative side who repealing
Obamacare is there a top thing so it's
not like I can't make the case
definitively that it's a bad political
move in a campaign I think as a policy
matter there are intrinsic policy
complications in transitioning out of a
system that has been built over time for
70 years you're talking about
as a literal matter I don't want to
sound hyperbolic but as a literal matter
this is a hostile government takeover of
an existing industry you can't come up
with an historical example where that
has happened in it in modern memory so
the insurance industry by definition are
literally fighting for their lives and
you might say well good no they they
[ __ ] we don't want profit health care
gonna screw them we should beat we
should we should take them out evidence
shows it's not that the insurance
industry is gonna buy off Congress
people and you're gonna lose or they
want to buy off Congress people you can
beat them with people power it's that
they're gonna be well resourced they're
gonna do their research they're gonna
find the weak spots in your argument and
they're and they're not going to be
undercut by a divide in their ranks
you know we had in the Obamacare fight
the Obamacare process Obama dealt with
the insurance Lobby dealt with the drug
lobby the insurance light you plead kind
of a double game and in the end they
give they gave mighty Chamber of
Commerce to defeat it but it wasn't like
the 90s with Harry and Louise where what
I mean those Harry Louise as in the
nineteen 1983 they were issued before
Bill and Hillary wrote the bill that's
how committed they were to defeating
Clinton care that wasn't the case with
Obamacare and the drug Lobby put in
millions of dollars they brought back
the Harry and Louise actors from the
1993 ads and used them in Pro Obamacare
ads so the Chamber of Commerce campaign
was was neutralized by that there was a
divide in the corporate community you
will not see that in a single-payer
fight you will face a unified front I
can't say this with certainty I suspect
that this insurance industry will go to
other corporations and say hey if they
can take us out if you could have a
hostile government take o our industry
they can do it to you too so you better
get on our side on this
that is just I think you you can't think
of a more ambitious ask than to
supplants a private industry with with a
single government entity yeah so I use
don't and thinking through what that
means politically how do you answer
people's questions
o-over you for exact hears for example
an obvious argument as well I'm gonna
raise your taxes but
you're gonna have no premiums you're
gonna have no co-pays you're gonna have
no deductibles that's a sweet deal
that's an easy target
once I articulate that properly people
are gonna get it and they're gonna come
on my side but you did not see in
Bernie's bill a provision that spells
out what those taxes are no I don't know
I mean you know Bernie said that that
would be in a separate bill and you can
criticize that decision you can
criticize putting the spending part in a
different you know how you pay for in a
different bill or you could say it makes
sense to keep the appropriations part of
it separate from the policy part but
that I mean there is a defense for that
which is yes it's not in that bill but
it will be discussed but point taken
nonetheless I mean I think you're right
that there there are a number of pretty
big matzo balls that remain hanging out
there that we sort of have to figure out
he would not have gotten 16 Democratic
co-sponsors many of whom are potential
presidential candidates if that tax
piece was in the bill because he knows
and they know that is hard to defend and
it's hard to defend because you you can
say it's gonna be a sweet deal for you
trust me trust me that you're gonna come
out better at the end of the day but
people there is some inherent distrust
the government out there whether we like
it or not and they're gonna say how do I
know that you're telling me it's gonna
cover everything you're telling me my
costs aren't gonna go up but how do I
know that's gonna be the case 10 years
after the bill passes and if you're
wrong if you come back to me 10 years
later and say oh I'm sorry it's more
expensive than I thought well where's my
recourse you're it's it's single payer
there is no other recourse that's a lot
to ask of people who many of whom in
surveys today say I am content with my
current health care it may be that their
contempt because they haven't gone into
jam yet but nevertheless you have to get
someone to say you can't save you like
your plan you can keep it you have to
say trust me this plan is better that is
hard politically to do if you made it be
hard politically in a campaign setting
we don't get all the details but in a
legislative setting you will get into
those details and it is tough alright
bill scher he said it all
I am getting ready for I'll just start
forwarding you emails later today bill
bill scher contributing editor to
Politico magazine thanks for talking to
us about this always a pleasure